[MUSIC]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> My first, last, and
only sex ed class took place in my eighth
grade biology teacher's living room.
It's not as creepy as it sounds but
it is a scary.
See, my high school didn't allow
us to be taught sex ed on campus.
So my 28 classmates and I got our
permission slips signed, put on our coats,
and walked a half mile up the road to Dr.
Ahmed's house.
Where we sat for an hour,
squeezed in couches, listening to a sex ed
teacher roll condoms onto bruised bananas.
One conversation,
one form of contraception.
Four of my girlfriends from growing up,
never made it to college,
they got pregnant before we graduated.
I’m not trying to draw a direct cause link
here, but I am trying to make a point.
This is crazy.
In the US, 51% of pregnancies
every year are unplanned.
That's half.
By the age of 45,
more than half of American women will
have had an unplanned pregnancy.
Half.
So, from you here on over today,
congratulations.
You're expecting.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Now you don't need to have a uterus to
be a part of this conversation either.
You could be friends with
someone with a uterus,
you could be related to someone with
a uterus, or perhaps most importantly,
you could be sleeping with
someone with a uterus.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And this conversation matters for
you too.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So what's happening here?
Why is this happening?
We're either not using contraceptives or
we're not using them effectively.
Let's take a hypothetical scenario.
Let's say every one in this
room is sexually active.
This is a hypothetical.
Say, you're chosen form of
contraception is a withdrawal method,
also known as pull and pray.
Over one year of typical use,
22% of us would become pregnant.
Say instead, your chosen form
of contraception is a condom,
over one year of typical use,
18% of us would still get pregnant.
Say instead, you use a pill,
pill is great everyone uses the pill.
Over one year of typical use 9%
of us would still get pregnant.
Say instead you use an IUD.
An IUD is an intrauterine device.
It's long acting,
reversible contraceptive.
Say instead your chosen form
of contraception is an IUD.
Over one year of typical use 0.2
to 0.8% of us would get pregnant.
If you get sterilized
the pregnancy rate is still 0.5%.
>> [LAUGH]
>> What I think is most interesting about
IUDs, I think a lot of things
are interesting about IUDs.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Is the difference in failure rates for
different kinds of birth control
under scenarios of perfect use.
I.e., how doctors tell us
we should use them, and
scenarios of typical use, i.e.,
how we actually use them.
What sets the IUD apart is what I like to
call the set it and forget it approach.
Once you have it inserted,
you don't have to think about it
again until you want it removed.
Awesome.
We must be using these, right?
Wrong.
In the US,
less than 6% of women use an IUD as
their personal form of contraception.
That is the lowest rate
of any developed country.
What is that?
Why in a country, so
used to being the best on so
many dimensions, we're not using the best
and most effective form of contraception?
There are a few reasons for that, but
the one I want to talk about today is
the fact that we're not talking about it.
We don't talk about sex and contraceptions
and reproductive health in this country.
Heck, we leave high school
campuses just to say the words.
That's lead to an increase in
misinformation and a decrease in awareness
about what the most effective
forms of contraception really are.
Namely IUDs.
So what can we do about it?
We can start the conversation.
Today I'm gonna answer three commonly
held questions about IUDs, so
together we can start
the conversation about contraception.
So, first question.
What are these?
First, I want to be clear.
These are not IED's,
the explosive devices.
>> [LAUGH]
>> These are IUD's,
intrauterine devices,
like the one shown here.
There are three main types in the US,
Mirena and
Skyla, which are plastic,
like the one shown here.
And Paragon, like this one,
just copper wire wrapped around it.
Mirena and Skyla work by releasing
low dose hormones in the body.
The equivalent of less than
one birth control pill a week.
Paraguard has copper wire wrapped
around it and has no hormones and
lasts in the body for
up to ten to 12 years.
Would you mind holding that?
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] IUDs work,
by disrupting the flow of
sperm availability, so
that they are unable to fertilize
an egg among other mechanisms.
They’re easily inserted in
the uterus in a 15 minute procedure,
although some women say it can
be painful or uncomfortable.
Okay, next question.
Aren’t they dangerous?
The first generation of IUD technology,
the Dalkon shield came on the market in
the 1970's and was responsible for
a host of negative health outcomes.
It was pulled from the market but
the stigma has persisted.
This new generation of IUD
technology is incredibly safe,
although it is a medical device so
certain risks persist.
Okay, fine, but what do they cost?
IEDU's cost anywhere from $300 to $700,
although many insurance plans cover
them in full, if not for a small copay.
If we take worst case scenario, $700, and
amortize that over the shortest
time period five years.
That works out to less than $11 a month.
That's literally less than the cost of
lunch at Arbuckle, our dining hall.
You compare that to the cost of
sending an unplanned child to college.
>> [LAUGH].
>> I think that comparison is pretty
clear.
So they work, they're safe,
and they're cost effective.
Now why aren't we using them?
Now it's time for a medical disclaimer.
I'm not a doctor, and
this is not a substitute for
a conversation with
a medical professional.
IUDs are a medical device, so
carry with them certain risks.
And some women are also
uncomfortable with the thought of
a foreign object in their body,
although this
whole conversation is predicated on
foreign objects in your body, so.
>> [LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE]
>> IUDs are part of a choice, however.
They're part of a choice
that each female makes and
many couples make together about
their reproductive health.
If IUDs are missing from the conversation,
then they're not a part
of that choice at all.
I wanna ask you to do something.
Think of the name of one person.
One person that you're going to have
a conversation with about contraception
in the next week.
It can be your partner,
a friend, a doctor, a spouse.
On the screen is a name of
a website you can go to for
more information if you want
help starting this conversation.
IUDs are one of the most effective
forms of contraception that exist and
we're not using them,
but we are having sex.
It's time to start the conversation
about contraception together.
So IUDs can become a part of that choice,
thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]